i
[Música]
ah
13 muertos y 75 heridos de bala
detención de defensores de los derechos
humanos y acusaciones de violencia
sexual contra una periodista este es el
balance de los sucesos violentos del 9 y
el 10 de septiembre en bogotá la capital
de colombia unas jornadas que empezaron
como una protesta contra la violenta
muerte del abogado javier ordóñez a
manos de la policía tras recibir más de
una decena de descargas eléctricas y
múltiples golpes una semana después ni
una destitución ni una dimisión en este
contexto son muchas las peticiones de
una reforma policial incluida la
alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez la
policía en colombia es militar el
conflicto armado ha impedido convertirla
en un cuerpo civil según la ong
temblores entre 2017 y 2019 morían 19
personas cada mes a manos de la policía
unos datos que no parecen inquietar al
presidente iván duque que no sólo ha
defendido la actuación policial sino que
se ha vestido como uno de ellos una
imagen que para muchos ha sido vista
como una falta de respeto a las víctimas
[Música]
en chile la llegada de la pandemia
supuso ver de nuevo al ejército en las
calles pocos días después de que se
identificara el primer caso de
coronavirus en el país el 3 de marzo el
presidente sebastián piñera declaraba un
estado de excepción que permite al
estado chileno contar con el recurso de
las fuerzas armadas el ejército ha
cumplido sobre todo la función de
vigilar el toque de queda que rige de
manera ininterrumpida en el país desde
el pasado 22 de marzo es decir van a
hacer seis meses en todo el territorio
nacional desde las diez de la noche
hasta las cinco de la mañana la semana
pasada el presidente sebastián piñera
alargaba este estado de excepción
durante 90 días estará en vigor hasta
mediados de diciembre y también en una
fecha clave para el país el próximo 25
de octubre cuando 14 millones de
chilenos están convocados a las urnas
para decidir si quieren reemplazar o no
la constitución heredada por la
dictadura de augusto pinochet lo cierto
es que tanto el ejército como la
pandemia ha ayudado al gobierno a
controlar algo que hasta hace poco
parecía incontrolable el estallido del
pasado 18 de octubre en el que miles de
chilenos salieron a las calles para
pedir un nuevo sistema económico y
social
[Música]
la cuarentena implementada en argentina
a partir del 20 de marzo le dio un rol
preponderante a las fuerzas de seguridad
a la hora de realizar controles de
circulación y de movimiento de personas
la situación de trabajo en pandemia se
convirtió también en argumento de
algunas de estas fuerzas y de sus
efectivos para realizar reclamos
salariales y de condiciones laborales
pero también se ha dado un incremento de
los casos de abuso de autoridad por
parte de estas fuerzas en el contexto de
pandemia abusos de autoridad que van
desde maltratos hasta detenciones
arbitrarias e incluso torturas y en
algunos casos muertes de acuerdo con
información de organismos de derechos
humanos es algo que corrobora la
secretaría de derechos humanos de la
nación con cifras oficiales que dan
cuenta que en algo más de tres meses
previos al inicio de la cuarentena
habían recibido 71 denuncias por abuso
de autoridad un número que en un poco
más de cuatro meses posteriores al
inicio de la cuarentena había subido a
531 denuncias